they asked Hunter Biden if he had the
qualifications to have that job at
barisma in the list you gave me of the
reasons why you're on that board you did
not list the fact that you were the son
of course yeah no what role do you think
that played I think that it is
impossible for me to be on any of the
boards that I just mentioned without
saying that I'm the son of the Vice
President of the United States you were
paid
thousand dollars a month for your
position look I'm a private citizen one
thing that I don't have to do is sit
here and open my kimono as it relates to
how much money I make or make a dinner
but it's all been reported if your last
name was in Biden do you think you would
have been asked to be on the board of
arisma I don't know I don't know
probably not I I don't think that
there's a lot of things that would have
happened in my life that uh that if my
last name wasn't fine I don't know how
would I know I was smoking crack I
didn't know what was going on you have
to understand he had no qualifications
zero qualifications in energy in
Ukrainian energy in international
relations he was a crackhead
okay but I'm sure there's some
functional crackheads out there I think
most numbers Democrats in Congress right
now okay but he he's he's saying it I I
don't know I don't know I don't know why
would I get this job why else would you
get the have any of you worked for a
Ukrainian Energy company
nobody in here is working Canadian
energy I never get a call free from a
Ukrainian Energy company I'm probably
more qualified and I'm not smoking crack
maybe that's why I'm not getting the gig
anyway in that interview he continued a
hunter to say that really what this was
about it wasn't about him it wasn't
about the crack and the laptop and
giving money to the big guy and peddling
influence and firing attorney generals
in Ukraine and any of that kind of stuff
for prosecutors in Ukraine it wasn't
about that it was about Rudy Giuliani
remember Rudy it was about Rudy and a
conspiracy to get Hunter do you regret
being on the board to begin with no I
don't regret being on the board but
would I regret is not taking into
account that there would be a Rudy
Giuliani
um and a um and a president of the
United States that would be listening to
this this ridiculous conspiracy idea
which has again been completely debunked
by every no it hasn't been debunked it's
been bunked but that doesn't really make
sense if something's debunked then is
bunk the opposite it doesn't sound right
bunk is the right way it was bunked like
it's true it doesn't really make sense
though you wouldn't say that's been well
you get the point guys it has not been
debunked The Conspiracy Theory it turned
out not to be a conspiracy theory and it
was not debunked it was bunked nobody
has to look into that that doesn't
really make sense they have debunked the
debunking I guess that much would be
true uh but the point is oh he's like
the one thing I regret is that Rudy said
made up some but of course Rudy
didn't make up some related to the
hunter Biden laptop he actually did not
he was willing to swear under oath the
Department of Justice didn't even wanna
when he was trying to give them the
laptop they didn't even want to look at
it because they knew it was legit and if
it was in their hands they were going to
be in a whole bunch of trouble and by
day I mean the Biden family
oh